Blockbusters have become the dominant form
of film in the 21st century, telling fantastical
tales full of stuff people can only dream
of.
It’s no secret why they’re so popular;
they provide audiences with escapism and are
usually prime illustrations of movie magic.
As great as many of these works are, there’s
no denying that trends that frequently pop
up in them have started to wear out their
welcome.
As the studios look for ways to push the creative
envelope in new and creative ways, hopefully
they find some solutions to 10 blockbuster
movie clichés you are definitely tired of.
Fake-Out Deaths
A surefire way to generate an emotional response
from the viewer is to tragically kill off
a fan-favorite character.
Not only is it a tear jerking moment, but
it can also underscore the high stakes and
illustrate that nobody is safe when the action
ramps up.
Unfortunately, with multi-picture contracts
becoming the norm, characters that “die”
on screen rarely stay dead.
This twist was effective when it first began,
but it’s been so overplayed now that deaths
have lost their meaning.
Now, it’s more of a surprise when a person
never returns, and that shouldn’t be.
If you want moviegoers to care, they have
to feel that the heroes are in some sort of
danger and can’t just come back whenever.
Final Installments Broken Up
Studio executives are always looking for ways
to make a quick buck, and one of the most
frustrating ways is to split the final installment
of a popular series into multiple parts, forcing
audiences to pay twice – or even three times
– to get the full story.
Starting with Harry Potter, this trend is
most prevalent in YA adaptations, but with
The Hunger Games and Divergent seeing diminishing
returns using this strategy, it seems that
audiences have voiced their displeasure with
their wallets.
Sequels are fine, but they want each entry
to tell a complete narrative with a clear
beginning, middle, and end.
Money Grabbing Sequels
If a studio strikes gold with a film, either
by design or surprise, their inclination is
to start working on the next one.
Since large crowds turned up once, they’ll
be eager to see another, right?
Turns out, modern audiences are becoming smarter
about which sequels they support.
As demonstrated by the recent disappointment
of Alice Through the Looking Glass, it seems
like the follow-up actually needs to have
high demand if it is to be a hit.
People nowadays can tell when the filmmakers
have an interesting story worth telling, or
when they’re just shamelessly trying to
cash in on a recognizable brand.
Trailers Spoiling Movies
For the most anticipated tentpoles, the premiere
of the trailer can become just as big an event
as the final film.
Fans can’t wait to get a look at the next
chapter of their favorite franchise, but frequently
are disappointed when the preview reveals
a bit too much about what the story entails.
Several trailers in recent years have spoiled
interesting plot developments and secrets
months before the movie comes out, ruining
what could have been a compelling moment for
the sake of hooking casual audiences.
With Star Wars setting records after The Force
Awakens remained shrouded in secrecy until
its release, hopefully the other studios learn
an important lesson in marketing.
Overreliance on CGI
Thanks to digital technology, anything is
possible and directors can see their wildest
dreams come to life.
But CGI has a tendency to be too much of a
good thing.
When a blockbuster is too reliant on splashy
visual effects, it loses something tangible
and real, which can hurt its connection with
the audience.
Film buffs enjoy seeing practical effects
because they make everything grounded and
relatable, even when it’s a galaxy far,
far away.
CGI certainly has its place in modern Hollywood,
but it should be used to compliment real world
materials and not just be a crutch for the
filmmakers to lean on.
Generic Villains
They say a story is only as good as its villain,
and that means a lot of blockbusters these
days are sort of mediocre.
Many heroes in recent years haven’t had
memorable foils to go up against, with the
Joker, Loki, and Kylo Ren serving as exceptions
to the rule.
Evildoers are frequently short changed by
the script and become plot devices instead
of compelling characters in their own right,
failing to leave a lasting impression.
It’s true that not everyone can be Darth
Vader, but with just a little more effort,
filmmakers can elevate villains from generic
to worthy opponent.
The bad guys can be more interesting than
the hero at times, so this one is really disappointing.
Lack of Diversity
If you look around the Marvel Cinematic Universe,
all of their films are led by white, male
actors.
This obviously hasn’t had a negative impact
on the brand’s popularity, but the movies
are hardly a reflection of the world they’re
released to.
Audiences are more diverse than ever, and
each demographic wants to be served equally.
This means it’s important to mix things
up a bit in terms of casting.
Star Wars made strides here by having John
Boyega and Daisy Ridley headline The Force
Awakens, and both Marvel and DC are giving
the spotlight to characters like Black Panther,
Wonder Woman, and others soon.
Looks like a new, more inclusive trend is
about to emerge.
Women as Eye Candy
In the old school of thinking, the hero saves
the day and then he gets the girl.
Several blockbusters depict female characters
as little more than objects of desire for
the male protagonist, at times exploiting
them for their good looks.
Even the strong Princess Leia had to wear
a golden bikini.
This understandably upsets some audience members,
who know that women are capable of being much
more than just a girlfriend.
Between Black Widow, Rey, and Wonder Woman,
the tide is beginning to change as more actresses
are given the chance to play well-rounded
characters that earn several fans.
Dark, Realistic Blockbusters
It worked for Christopher Nolan’s Batman,
but not every franchise is designed for a
dark, gritty tone.
Most titles are created differently, and need
a film that best conveys its intended feel.
Superman is meant to be a beacon of light
and hope, but Man of Steel provided a more
serious spin on the material.
The Fantastic Four are supposed to be fun
and light-hearted, which is why the po-faced
2015 reboot failed miserably.
Trying something different is always welcomed,
but the approach needs to be a fit for the
source material.
Several of these stories aren’t meant to
be “realistic” in that sense of the word,
so filmmakers need to learn to lighten up
a bit.
Subplots That Set Up Sequels
The dawn of the shared universe has essentially
turned franchise filmmaking into big screen
TV, and that hasn’t sat well with some.
Many viewers go into a movie expecting a complete
story and want everything introduced to have
some kind of payoff.
With multiple installments planned out years
in advance, studios have begun to introduce
certain elements and story beats in the current
film that won’t be explored until much later
on, giving them a disjointed feel.
There has to be a reason for why something
is included in a movie, or it’s going to
leave certain audiences confused.
There’s a reason why the best Marvel movies
tend to be the ones separate from the connected
storyline.
Those are our picks for blockbuster trends
audiences are tired of.
Are there any we missed?
Which ones do you want to see eliminated from
Hollywood?
Sound off in the comments section below and
be sure to subscribe to our channel for more
fun videos like this one!